[Music]
Geo
if a TSA agents or nobody was doing I
was trying to follow at LAX told you
that you needed to go to an elevator for
a secondary inspection and then this TSA
agent told you that he needed to see
your full breasts to make sure there's
nothing being hidden down your pants or
would you fall for it yeah no I wanted
to keep America I hope I want it I want
to keep America safe if they need to see
inside my dick hole I have nothing on
this yeah but I want to say no how
gaping is your unit it's pretty tight
but for America it's pretty tight before
America will stretch it out it is how
does your pee stream look is its brain
is it like dripping down or does it
shoot straight it is that big is this
one drop it rolls out if it's spraying
then it's a phillips-head I don't think
it comes out as a cube I'm trying to
figure out oh then you have a big-ass
hole its gaping mass just I wish my hole
was bigger
do you cuz like sometimes I'll go pee
right and then when I'm peeing it takes
me a long time to pee because I think my
whole small mm-hmm so it's like and I
hear another dude walk by and it's just
like and they're done yeah some people
feel like yeah IV just dumped it like
you just dumped this bladder all out but
it's like a water balloon with the
little needle you gotta squeeze you
gotta keep going to get tight baby you
know I'm taking like 60 seconds to piece
of times I had a suit ossifer you when I
go up your urethra with this camera yeah
and it was not fun because they have
like they literally stretch it but you
go fast now were you awake I was awake
yeah cuz it's outpatient now yeah they
just what they do is like numb it they
get a syringe and so the gel goes in and
nums it and then the doctor comes in and
he sticks the camera up there
the camera has light on it and it also a
shooting water a whole time so when it
actually makes it through like the
thready pulse it out is he like yeah you
get the sensation you got a piece when
as he gets like inside to start looking
at your bladder and then you start
peeing while it's in there I didn't but
he said I could cuz he was like if you
got a pee go ahead and go I was like I
don't want to stop unless the spitter
seems like oh we don't have to stop I
was like hey let me feel your hands is
like people do it all the time he's
alright I thought you need to switch
jobs really wait please so a different
world you don't do that one don't do it
like go to jail
he's like people pay me they put glass
down it's like my man people pay me 200
G's a year no I'm good
oh yes answer Birds question though do P
faster now no no it went back it closed
back up oh so I thought a good gauge
maybe she's looking to a gauge so wait
take your tits out for the for the
country that's what we're getting
so she's unpatriotic is what we're
together no she is because she did it oh
no
but the TSA agent was a guy in a blue
shirt and he was an agent he acted like
the best buy I need to go to that
elevator
alright so what happened here was this
twenty two-year-old TSA agent named
Jonathan he did what I the the whole
scenario that I just it was a real agent
yes a real TSA agent and so only twenty
two-year-old this chick she had already
so she didn't have proper identification
on her and that's the reason why she
needed like additional screening gotta
look at your tip to know it's really you
she did end up getting additional
screening with a female officer and so
or agent and so once that female agent
cleared her that's when this dude pops
in he's like oh wait you gotta come this
way that's a [ __ ] yeah so that's
like this elevator and then he told her
that he needed to show me your full
breasts but do it before we hit the
fourth floor that's pretty crazy
so the the victim here she ended up she
said that she was in fear of him
inappropriately touching her so she
complied and so he ended up and she did
it twice
wait she was a wife of him touching her
so she showed him her titties yeah I get
it
wait how does that work so she feels
like he was if she didn't do what he
said he was gonna just do it preemptive
strike yeah I'd rather have him look at
it then to come over and physically
touch ya so he also asked her to like
move her pants so she can look down her
pants did he say like do you want to
inspect me and show him and pull down
his pants he maybe did that that's that
would be fair it's back teacher yeah in
the elevator there's no cameras that's
crazy yeah I'll show you my
identification there's a lot of
elevators that do have cameras i likey
compliment her compliment her so she had
a nice nice breasts well I wonder why he
pulled her over all right so you're
clear to go man by the way nice tits
well that's the bet if that's our
identification card iden that's how I
like your picture I know what I'm glad
you're not a terrorist but on the other
hand I don't want you to be
self-conscious because you just showed
me your titties cool titties how does he
get out of this right so they send
another like yo man you can't do this
[ __ ] he's like that's not professional
like no you know what because eight days
later eight days after this happened he
resigned and so this happened back in
June this past June and so not until
recently so how many months eight months
is when he got arrested at his home oh
hell yeah
monster girl man dude this [ __ ]
could not resist looking at a woman's
breasts at the airport and then he's
trying to cover up his tracks he's like
I gotta [ __ ] claim that type of [ __ ]
it's close
like though porn is free you don't even
have to go to a site you go to Twitter
and this is like titties everywhere he's
probably getting off on the power yeah
show me your titties girl [ __ ] yeah
there were six agencies involved
including the FBI the Los Angeles Police
Department and the TSA what happened in
LA
yeah and lax I like that too Joe if you
just told this to us a guy like hey man
you know there's T's on the internet
he's like wait really
I know man so crazy so he is now in jail
or actually he got released from jail on
a 50-thousand dollar bond all he's going
back to jail yeah they just gonna take
it's a trial he's going to jail well
they probably were like trying to build
the case for how often has he done this
though the end that's all say it like
was this the first time it might have
been the first time because if he quit
right after that that's probably so he's
like he was freaked out by he didn't
know that he's like yes finally got
caught could be that so they're wrong to
him you know he's like I've done this to
too many women I think he thinks he's
like I'll do the right thing I'll resign
and we'll call it even
like what no man doesn't work like that
you've already come into the ground it's
like you stole the money for the bank
well I got a guy's I I renounce my
burglary days I'm not doing this anymore
I'm gonna keep this money no I quit last
night guys I feel bad for this chick
though cuz on what if she's like not
used to the whole like like the
screening she might not travel that much
yep she didn't bring identification so
that is it's a a sign to me that she
doesn't she probably didn't even realize
how [ __ ] up it was until she was
talking to people and people like yeah
that's not normal oh well oh you guys
are so hot to go through TSA no way it's
[ __ ] to get on the plane you're
supposed to do the [ __ ] being in the
tube and there's a bunch of people no no
no I did that I did that but then I had
additional screening well he's like
needed to see this detect my tonsils
yeah and then he said he needed to check
my vagina just to make sure no that's
not right but isn't that why we're
supposed show up two hours early so we
have [ __ ] time and didn't have time
that's wrong you hiding a grenade in my
vagina that's what I'm saying that's or
landmine oh my god right and it hit her
I don't think that was legal it was not
like that's right took 8 months that's
[ __ ] crazy
that sucks right when did she report it
or like the investigation took 8 months
well he it took 8 months for him to get
arrested so I don't know exactly when
she they needed to build a case on his
ass if it's federal
they definitely build a case they want
to know how many other women did they
catch cuz if they're going through trial
they might have caught other women that
went through this [ __ ] or like other
women can it just be this one chick and
I think that's enough do you think that
to cover it up this guy's like how do I
get a grenade up this chick's pagina do
they make them so he could be like ha I
told you boom I was doing something for
America justified no she doesn't have a
grenade though the crazy thing is that
when he gets his jab they're gonna want
to see his tits but he's gonna like a
toaster strudel that's when I feel
that's what I want people to be raped is
one day when they violated other people
or it's like it's like but for a buck
sitting next to you is so hard sometimes
I don't know where it's coming from
I tell you man way to interrogate
somebody stick something in the back no
no no no just like you got a guy in the
interrogation room he's like I ain't
talking ain't going for that [ __ ] I
ain't talking to you peace like okay you
know what the talk bring it Tyrell
they bring in his big swole [ __ ]
hairy dude he's got baby all along yeah
he's just right there just stroking
I put him in a sail with me like who was
he this is he's in a holding cell this
is what you got to go tonight until we
can clear this up like technically we
can only hold you for 24 hours like that
how only needs 30 minutes please just
like I actually listed the jail Avengers
of every race black guy named Tai ruled
you got an Asian guy that's [ __ ] seven
feet tall like y'all me what a big-ass
dick you got like a bisexual guy who can
float yeah you got a neo-nazi biker and
[ __ ] you got like the Mexican Mafia they
all round they just all come out they
got big-ass sticks they got big [ __ ]
dicks like that they're like are you
ready they even got a Russian mobster
come on come to Zangief come to thank
you it's like The Avengers of the racial
criminals so we'll use rape as a way to
prevent crime yeah yeah I love it I do
know if you if people threaten you with
that right oh my god yeah man we're
gonna run up inside mobile have you seen
the new date guys that they and they
should put them on billboards - it's
like a Chippendales but it's like the
rape Avengers it's like they're all just
[ __ ] you don't want to come see us or
did you just have a big dick like
they're holding it and they're like are
you ready for this be good yeah Oh like
that he won't like me when I'm horny I
like that I'm in a video we're talking
earnestly about what would happen if we
had a rape Avengers and how cool would
be I think that this will work out fine
for me no consequence
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]